سيارات صينيه تنشرها روسيا على الخطوط
الاماميه في الحرب مع اوكرانيا ترفع مستوى
القلق الغربي لاكثر من سبب حسب وسط جان
روسيا التي دابت على استخدام هذه المسيرات
تواصل شرائها من الشركات المصنعه في الصين
عبر طرف ثالث لتلتف بذلك على العقوبات
الغربيه
البنتاجون حذر من ان هذه الطائرات المسيره
الصينيه لا تغذي فقط المجهود الحربيه
الروسي فهي ذات استخدام مزدوج تسمح ايضا
للصين بجمع معلومات استخباراتيه حاسمه من
ساحه المعركه قد تعزز استعدادات بكير لاي
حرب مستقبليه كما ان تستغل الفرصه لاختبار
مدى تاثر هذه المسيرات بهجمات الحرب
الالكترونيه من اجل تحسين قدراتها مستقبلا
بالنسبه الى كيف الهاجس الاساسي من هذه
المسيرات الصينيه هو ان روسيا تستخدمها من
اجل توجيه افضل للصواريخها باتجاه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه
مع هذه التطورات حضر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انجوني بلينكن من الذهاب ابعد
وتوعدها بعواقب وخيمه اذا ارسلت اسلحه الى
روسيا
الى ان المعلومات المتوفره لدى تؤكد ان
تدرس تحويل دعمها الماديه لروسيا الان الى
دعم عسكري
التحذيرات الامريكيه تسبق زياره وفد صني
رفيع المستوى الى موسكو وصفته الاخيره
بانه لتعميق الشراكه بين البلدين